- no stars in Hollywood's galaxy will
present the awards for short substance
the movie version of Ida and Eddie
Cantor that's Marilyn Erskine and Keith
Purcell the nominations for the best
achievement in cartoons short subjects
are Christopher crumpet United
productions of America Colombia Steven
miss austero producer from A to Z Z Z Z
Warner Brothers cartoons Edwards Seltzer
producing rugged bear Walt Disney RKO
radio Walt Disney producer the tell-tale
heart
United productions of America Colombia
Stephen bestow producer to whistle plunk
and boon Walt Disney when a vista film
distributors walt disney producer and
the winner please the winner is tube
whistle prankin boom workers new
production
well I just want to say on behalf of my
staff and especially the The Naturalist
photographers who have played such a
great part in making the nature films
many many thanks
nominations for achievement in one real
short subjects are Christ among the
primitives Italian IFE releasing
corporation
Vincenzo Lucci Kia Ricci producer
herring Hunt Canadian National Film
Board of Canada
RKO path a joy of living art films 20th
Century Fox
Boris Vermont producer The Merry Wives
of Windsor overture metro-goldwyn-mayer
Johnny green produces we water wonders
paramount Jack Eaton producer the winner
please the winner the Merry Wives of
Windsor / cherry
thank you ladies and gentlemen and a
very special word of thanks to my
talented associate mr. George Sidney
those nominated for achievement in two
real short subjects are bear country
Walt Disney RKO radio Walt Disney
producer Ben and me Walt Disney when
Avista film distributors walt disney
producing return to Glennis call Dublin
gate theatre production Arthur mayor
Edward Kingsley Vesuvius Express
20th Century Fox Otto Lange producer
winter paradise Warner Brothers
Cedric Francis producing and the winner
is bear country
I just gotta say one more word it's uh
it's wonderful but I think this is my
year to retire
they're wonderful that's a pretty great
man